bravo just fired four vanderpump rules
cast members after recently resurfaced
insensitive race comments
the most notable 31 year old stassi
schroeder
one of the show's original and most
popular stars
i'm like really sick of everyone making
everything about rice
i hope you school saucy under privilege
because this
actually takes pride in being ignorant
so you know what
saying that i'm racist it's a whole
other level of vindictiveness
why is it always just about
african-americans like
why aren't the asians being like we're
not represented
there's more a podcast resurfaced of
stasi talking about a 2018
incident involving faith stowers she was
the only african-american on vanderpump
rules that season
we start calling the police stasi and
fellow cast member kristen doty who was
also fired reported faith to authorities
for a crime she did not commit
i go person that is one hundred percent
faith briston sees that she's at
a club that's in west hollywood chris
bless her goes
calls the west hollywood police again it
was racial profile
you knew it wasn't me this morning faith
brought back tears
yeah i told myself i was like a cry
again this time it sounded like a movie
um a really bad movie what i was
uh happy about was bravo taking the time
to give a voice back to the people and
say we hear you and that made me feel
really really really really good because
i i didn't
think that it would go that far also
fired
vanderpump newcomers brett capriani and
max boyens
the reason tweets from max and brett's
past
that are very racially inappropriate and
inseparable
the tweets were discussed on last week's
pre-taped reunion special and it seemed
like all had been forgiven
i'm an adult now and i cringe even
thinking that i said those things
it wasn't okay then it's not okay now if
i fired every one of you that
made mistakes probably none of you would
have a job this morning bravo host andy
cohen weighed in
i absolutely support bravo's decision i
think it was
the right decision and atlanta housewife
nene leakes responded well alrighty then
now we have a few more questions to ask
should we talk
privately or publicly do you think the
show should be canceled
um no i think the show is a is a great
great idea i just think that maybe they
could put people out there that could
you know
um give a voice to people because
there's no people of color on that show
um i think it needs to be revamped and
it needs to be done right and
there are calls for one more cast member
to go
someone said that i hooked up with faith
jax taylor who cheated on his girlfriend
with faith on the show
also accused faith of criminal activity
in the past
should he be fired too
i think he's probably had more
um more terrible things to say than
these two young ladies it seems like
he continues to get away with everything
he does
and i'm not sure why